about your announcement today and we
concerned that companies that were
making new products well they become
very rich companies very fast and the
whole thing with vaping is is a very
profitable and I want companies look you
know that I fight for our companies very
hard if I fight that's why I'm fighting
with China that's why I'm fighting with
other countries if you look at European
Union and if you look at Japan and if
you look at so many others including
South Korea and many others were
constantly dealing with them to make it
good for our companies because I view it
as jobs I view it as income for our
country and jobs vaping has become a
very big business as I understand it
like a giant business that are very
short period of time but we can't allow
people to get sick and we can't have our
youth be so affected and I'm hearing it
and that's how the first lady got
involved she's got a son together that
is a beautiful young man and she feels
very very strongly about it she's seen
it
we're both reading it a lot of people
are reading it but people are dying with
a thing so we're looking at it very
closely and you know if nothing else
this is a conference it's gonna let
people know about it because people are
gonna watch what we're saying and
parents are going to be a lot tougher
with respect to their children a lot of
people think vaping is wonderful it's
great it's really not wonderful that's
one thing I think we can say definitely
commissioner it's not a wonderful thing
it's got big problems we have to find
out the extent of the problem it's so
new and so no but we're gonna find out
and I hope that parents that you know
they have children and the children in a
certain age I hope they're going to be
able to make wise decisions maybe based
on what we're saying today but the
Commissioner and Alex Hayes are they
going to be coming back over the next
short period of time a couple of weeks
with some very strong recommendations
you tell it'll take several weeks for us
to put out the final guidance that would
announce the all the parameters around
the enforcement policy and then there
will likely be about a 30-day delayed
effective date as is customary with
FDA's good guidance practices and at
that point all flavored e-cigarettes
other than tobacco flavor would have to
be removed from the market tobacco
flavor it's a cigarettes their
manufacturers would by May 20-22 file
for approval by FDA of their products
the other flavored product manufacturers
can at any time also filed but they
would be off the market until approved
by FDA the Obama administration had
allowed these products to go onto the
market in an unregulated way by delaying
any enforcement in the hopes that people
who were using combustible tobacco would
transition to a less harmful form of
nicotine delivery three cigarettes but
what we've seen is the data just shows
the kids are getting access to these
products in spite of our best efforts at
enforcement at retail enforcement at
controlling locations at over 8,000
warning letters to retailers and others
in spite of moving products off shelves
they've been going at it so we simply
have to remove these attractive labor
products from the marketplace until they
secure FDA approval at they